bueno buenas tardes en los barrios
cercanos al palacio de la justicia donde
esta mañana estaba convocada la protesta
contra el juez para evitar parece que la
calma se ha retomado un poquito o por lo
menos los disparos han desaparecido esto
ha ocurrido después de que hace cosa de
una hora el ejército haya entrado en
algunos barrios desde donde hace horas
los tiroteos persistían
a pesar de eso la jornada ha dejado
imágenes de mucha tensión se han visto
colegios amontonando a niños y niñas en
los pasillos para protegerlos de un
eventual estallido oa personas no se
sabe si civiles o si a militantes de
algún partido político
usando lanzacohetes en calles
residenciales de virus ahora ya van cómo
va la investigación sobre la explosión
en este puerto y por qué el descontento
de las personas
bueno la verdad que esta es una
investigación que sufre un bloqueo
continuo por parte de la clase política
antes ya hicieron presión hasta expulsar
al juez que lideraba la investigación y
ahora hacen lo mismo con el actual líder
de la investigación que es tareck evitar
en la campaña de presión y de
desprestigio la lideran tanto hezbollah
como sus aliados que acusan a evitar de
forma por cierto injusta de estar
apuntando su investigación únicamente
contra ellos hay que entender que esta
es una investigación que puede suponer
un punto de inflexión en líbano que es
un país que hace décadas que es
gobernado por un sistema al que muchos
conocen como el régimen de la impunidad